[Music]
new york magazine calls her the queen of
beach reads and for a very good reason
ellen hildebrand has written 27 novels
all of them best sellers think about
that for a second all of
them every single one yeah i did not
stutter she is a badass most are based
on
nantucket island off the massachusetts
coast hildebrand's breezy story lines
and sandy beaches inspire her legions of
fans
starting today they'll get a chance like
us to meet her in person she's at the
table
as pandemic restrictions ease up she's
beginning a 13-stop book tour but right
now she's starting
with us ellen hildebrand's latest novel
is called golden girl and she joins us
at the table good morning
golden girl that really could be you by
the way thank you good morning guys
so great to have you here it really is
it really is to
touch you to hug you we're all
vaccinated i'm so glad to see you but
i have to talk about this book ellen
because i was deeply affected by it i'll
tell you
why in just a second when my mom died
oprah did the eulogy and in the eulogies
he said
now gail you have an angel in heaven who
knows your name her name is peggy king
who's looking out for you
in this book you have the main character
dies very early on i'm not giving
anything away
and she's up in heaven looking down and
i often wondered
can they really see us when they're up
there looking down
and i thought that that was an odd
question but you you answer it so
beautifully in the book
and it really is inspired by things that
had happened in your life too
losing someone very close to you that's
right so the genesis of this book came
from two places
i lost my father in a plane crash when i
was 16 years old
and that was shocking devastating tragic
and ever since then i've always sort of
felt his hand on my back
in fact he's watching me now saying el
nailed the interview
and then 29 years later as you know i
was battling breast cancer
and i got very very sick i had an
infection in my blood
and i was on in the hospital on last
line hospital strength antibiotics
and i had to be flown in the helicopter
from nantucket to boston medical center
and the nurse at the hospital said you
probably should say goodbye to your kids
wow so i had a friend go get them out of
school brought them to my hospital room
and i said to them you guys i don't know
what's gonna happen here but i can tell
you one thing
i will never leave you what did you mean
by that so i really wasn't sure what i
meant by that
and then this book golden girl is an
exploration
of of what i meant by that and your
dedication to my children maxwell dawson
and shelby i will never leave you yeah
takes on a whole different meaning once
you read the book you're here looking
like a golden girl very golden indeed
you mark summer your presence here mark
summer for so many people
the arrival of your your new novel this
character has
a lot in common with you so much so that
i wonder what parts are not you
good question well i like to say vivi is
way cooler than i am um she humbles her
best selling author
she is a best-selling author i was able
to use a lot of like the fun details of
being a novelist
you know there's some professional
jealousy in there there's like the
struggle like with the new york times
uh book review and then the touring part
she goes on tour she's a newly single
mom
and being away from her kids is really
difficult so i got to talk about that
i got to talk about the parenting of
young adults which is
very challenging and she handles it so
beautifully
meanwhile the new york times calls this
your 27th book
your best book which must feel amazing
it does i mean in theory i believe when
authors are writing one of your like i
am
every book should get better because you
grow as a person
you know your craft you're i'm
constantly reading and your craft should
get better but i would think actually
that
coming up with the ideas year after year
and the impression of a pressure of that
must be
really heavy yes it's awful in fact i
always say like my job is to do exactly
the same thing
every year completely differently but
this is very different though
so here's vivi she's up in heaven it's
it's weird because
she's telling the story in real time
she's dead she's no longer with us
she's telling the story in real time she
has a viewing window that she can look
there are nudges
where she gets to come back and help
people she only gets three of them
and what what what rattled me about this
book is vivi is waiting for her first
grandchild as am i
in september vivi's a good person and
she dies early on
i know and i was so rattled by that
ellen i know i don't want to be scared
when i'm reading a book
it's certainly not a beach read it feels
unfair it doesn't it
but life isn't fair but life isn't fair
what's the message you're sending well i
wanted people who read the book to feel
like a lot of us most of us have lost
someone yeah before their time and so
for those people
i wanted them to feel a sense of comfort
a sense of optimism and a sense of joy
when you read the book i mean what
happens in the beyond in my book
is very comforting and it is helpful
also the way you talk about food
i wanted to go to the nickel this
restaurant deviled egg with crispy bacon
on lamb's lettuce on a toasted olive
sourdough
roll okay or grilled salmon and
anthony's like okay
wait grilled salmon fresh spinach
with raspberry dill aioli what's for
dessert
on a brioche roll oh my god
i just thought is that a real plate it's
not i
made that
you've talked pretty openly about
potentially retiring from novel writing
after three more novels i don't believe
it is a cookbook in your future
i i hope so i hope so that would
definitely be something post-retirement
though because i'm way too busy now but
people ask all the time is this a
retirement really a hard wall you're
really going to like
i hope so i hope to have a model i want
to go out on top
but in the meantime you're going out on
an in-person book tour
how exciting that much i'm thrilled yeah
you're not nervous being out there with
the people oh not at all
i know i had 200 people some of them
won't be vaccinated
i know well they take their their
chances
they're taking their chances because
you're saying you are vaccinated right
okay absolutely
and your daughter last time you were
here shelby for the first time your
only daughter youngest daughter had read
one of your books the boy your sons
still haven't did shelby read this one
shelby red golden girl
gave it a thumbs up she was trying to
figure out which character was her
um she's 15. that's what she was
concerned about
but back to what anthony said about the
new york times the sweeping love story
is her best
ever her stories are relatable and
aspiration her attention to detail
is what makes characters feel like
breathing living breathing people you
want to know
bravo next year somehow i know somehow
we'll try to top
that ellen hildebrandt this should be a
movie oh my god for sure fingers crossed
it should be a movie ellen hildebrand we
thank you good luck out on the road
thank you
cheering you on always golden girls on
sale today wherever you like to buy your
books